Titans first season finale came with no
shortage of surprises with mind-bending
plot twists and an exciting tease of a
post-credits scene but the episodes
dreamlike quality makes it easy to
wonder what really happened confused by
it all don't worry let's break down the
climax of titans season 1 most of the
finale is a hallucination brought on by
Trigon Rachel super villain of a father
in this fake reality Dick Grayson
believes he's married to dawn with the
two having a young son and a baby on the
way
gar and Raven are off at college life
seems to be going great for dick until
Jason Todd arrives in wheelchair to warn
dick that Batman has finally cracked and
is on the verge of turning from a crime
fighter to a vengeful murderer dick
returns to Gotham to see if he can stop
his mentor from killing the Joker but he
fails once Batman starts killing he
can't stop and everyone in Arkham is on
his hit list
it gives Batman's secret identity to the
GCPD and helps lead a mission to raid
his home but Batman is ready for them
and kills almost all of the cops
including Corey who appears in this
reality as an FBI agent dick then blows
the house up and goes after Batman
himself when Batman reaches out to his
old Ward for help it kills him instead
and that's when the show returns to the
real world turns out nothing in Dick's
trip to Gotham was real except for the
emotions he felt in the choices he made
Trigon himself appears in the vision as
a GCPD detective but none of the other
characters were actually there he was
all in dicks head Trigon used the gotham
hallucination to possess dick after dick
kills batman the show returns to the
same house where we last saw Trigon
Raven and Angela Ravens biological
mother dicks eyes are black and sinister
and to ravens horror he appears to be
completely under trigons control but why
did Trigon go through the trouble of
toying with dick before he took him over
he wasn't just playing with his food
Trigon needed the gotham hallucination
for his plan to work i offered you a
friend a path
they wound down many roads but
ultimately he chose his own way the
season's 7th episode ended with dick
burning his Robin suit symbolizing his
rejection of the darker urges he faced
going after his parents killer
Trigon needed to drag dick back down to
that dark place and the Gotham
hallucination was his way of doing it he
pushed him to the point of committing
one of the darkest acts he could imagine
killing his own mentor dick didn't
really kill Batman but it felt real to
him and that was enough once he stepped
over that line he opened the door for
trigons influence at the end of episode
10 Corey and Donna Troy both try to
follow dick into the house where Trigon
was summoned but they're blocked by an
invisible barrier only dick is allowed
to pass through so why did Trigon want
Grayson and none of the others why
possess him rather than kill him Titans
showrunner Greg Walker told TV Line the
Trigon let's stick into the house
specifically to turn him to his side and
the reason why quote has a lot to do
with trigons plan for Rachel it suggests
that Trigon needs more from his daughter
than to simply have her bring him into
the world whatever his master plan is
this is only the beginning in the
season's second-to-last episode we
learned that angela is just as committed
to bringing Trigon into the world as her
former captors work she doesn't switch
sides she was working with Trigon all
along who's this
Rachel's mother paler cozy the reveal
begs the question of why Angela was
being held in the asylum the Titans
freed her from in the season seventh
episode it could be that making Angela
appear to be a prisoner was all a part
of the plan
giving the Titans a reason to trust her
when it turns out they really shouldn't
episode 8 of Titans
ends with Rachel restoring Corey's lost
memories which turns out to be a bad
idea when Corey then attacks her Corey
remembers that she's an alien from the
planet tamarin
sent to earth for the express purpose of
killing Rachel in order to stop her from
summoning Trigon but by season's end
rachel has successfully brought Trigon
into the world in a way the damage is
done even if Corey wanted to kill Rachel
what would be the point maybe now she
won't have to and can use her formidable
powers to fight Trigon instead for the
most part the real beast boy appears to
be absent from the finale but his
presence can still be felt in dicks
hallucination
shortly before dick leaves for Gotham
and his vision his son gives him his
favorite toy a stuffed tiger to protect
him on his journey the tiger was a gift
from gar which is more than just on
brand for the beast boy
it could also have a deeper meaning it
could be that gar now has some kind of
psychic connection with dick acting as
an antidote of sorts to trigons
influence it might be just the sign dick
needs to snap back to reality in season
2 episode 9 focuses on Hank and Dawn aka
Hawk and of showing us their origin
story as dawn recovers from her fight
with the nuclear family but their
flashbacks are curiously interrupted by
calls for help from Rachel which seemed
to be intruding before they ever met her
in real life what's going on why did
Rachel send her messages into the past
and how did she do it in the comics it
was shown as early as her first
appearance that Rachel's psychic powers
could play havoc with time it seems
likely that the same thing is happening
in Titans and she might not even know
she's doing it either way the hero
seemed to take notice of her cries for
help when dawn wakes up in the hospital
she tells Hank they need to go find
Jason tie with one Robin under trigons
control maybe teaming up with the second
one can help turn things around the last
moments of the season finale featured
the potential introduction of two more
DC heroes and they might just change the
show's whole dynamic the scene features
a naked figure hidden in shadows raging
through Cadmus laboratories in
Metropolis with dead
or dying scientists sprawled out across
the floor as the man opens up a cage to
free a dog he shows a telltale s symbol
just before the screen goes black the
dog's eyes glow bright red it's all but
certain that the naked man and his dog
are none other than Superboy and Krypto
while DC comics have had multiple
characters with the name of Superboy one
of them was con el a clone of Superman
developed by Cadmus labs how would he
and Krypto play into season 2 that's
still a mystery one that will probably
have to wait until dick is back on the
side of the light check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]